DANA PERINO AND GREG GUTFELD.
IT'S 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY AND
THIS IS "THE FIVE" ."
THERE HAS BEEN YEARS AND YEARS
OF TALKS BY PRESIDENTS ABOUT
MAKING OUR CHILDREN SAFE AGAIN
IN THEIR CLASSROOMS.
THIS PRESIDENT IS DETERMINED TO
FINALLY GET IT DONE.
>> PEOPLE SITTING IN MY POSITION
DID NOT TAKE ACTION.
THEY DIDN'T TAKE PROPER ACTION.
THEY TOOK NO ACTION AT ALL.
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE ACTION.
WE'RE GOING TO DO STRONG
BACKGROUND CHECKS.
WE ARE GOING TO WORK D AT THE
AGE UP TO 21 INSTEAD OF 18.
GETTING RID OF THE BUMP STOCKS
AND FOCUSING STRONGLY ON MENTAL
HEALTH.
>> Kimberly: MR. TRUMP HELD
ANOTHER SIT DOWN TODAY, THIS
TIME WITH STATE AND LOCAL
OFFICIALS FROM ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
IN ADDITION TO GUN LAW REFORMS
AND MENTAL HEALTH SCREENING, THE
PRESIDENT SUGGESTED ARMING SOME
TEACHERS TO DETER SCHOOL
SHOOTINGS.
>> WE HAVE TO HARDEN OUR
SCHOOLS, NOT SOFTEN THEM UP.
A GUN FREE ZONE TO A KILLER OR
SOMEBODY THAT WANTS TO BE A
KILLER, THAT'S LIKE GOING IN FOR
THE ICE CREAM.
THAT'S LIKE "HERE I AM.
TAKE ME."
ONE OF THE FAKE NEWS NETWORKS,
CNN SAID I SAID I WANTED
TEACHERS TO HAVE GONE.
I WANT HIGHLY ADEPT PEOPLE WHO
UNDERSTAND WEAPONRY, GUNS.
IF THEY HAVE THAT APTITUDE.
I THINK A CONCEALED PERMIT FOR
HAVING TEACHERS AND LETTING
PEOPLE KNOW THEIR PEOPLE IN THE
BUILDING WITH GUNS, IN MY
OPINION YOU WON'T HAVE THE
SHOOTINGS.
THESE PEOPLE ARE COWARDS.
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO WALK INTO
A SCHOOL IF 20% OF THE TEACHERS
HAVE GUNS.
>> Kimberly: NOT EVERYONE IS
ON BOARD WITH THAT IDEA.
A LOT OF PROGRESS IN TERMS OF
THE LAST TWO DAYS, GETTING
PEOPLE TOGETHER, GREG, TO TALK
ABOUT THESE ISSUES,
BRAINSTORMING COMING UP WITH
IDEAS.
THE PRESIDENT NOW HAS SOME
SPECIFICS HE SEEMS TO BE SEIZING
UPON.
>> Greg: IT'S INTERESTING THAT
MOST OF THE PRACTICAL SOLUTIONS
ARE COMING FROM REASONABLE
PEOPLE, PEOPLE WHO KNOW
STATISTICS, UNDERSTAND WEAPONRY
AND CAN SPEAK RATIONALLY.
I HAVE TO SAY WE HAVE GONE
THROUGH THIS A LOT.
A LOT OF THE SHOOTINGS.
ESPECIALLY WITH "THE FIVE" OVER
THE LAST SIX YEARS, WE HAVE
MENTIONED SPECIFICALLY THESE
VERY SOLUTIONS.
WE HAVE TALKED ABOUT HARDENING
SOFT TARGETS.
I REMEMBER EVERY TIME THERE WAS
A SHOOTING I WOULD SAY THE SAME
THING ABOUT FOX NEWS -- WE ARE
SURROUNDED BY SECURITY AND THE
PEOPLE WHO TALK ABOUT GUN
CONTROL ON TV ARE SURROUNDED BY
SECURITY.
WHEN YOU'RE ON CNN OR MSNBC OR
WHATEVER, THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO
CREATE A LOOP OF FABULIST ARMED
SECURITY SO THEY CAN TELL YOU
WHY YOU SHOULD HAVE A GUN.
WE HAVE TALKED ABOUT DATABASES.
MY POINT IS IT AMAZES ME HOW
NARROW THE MEDIA IS ON THIS
TOPIC.
THEY ACT AS IF THEY'VE NEVER
HEARD THESE THINGS BEFORE, THAT
THESE ARE ALL MIND-BLOWING.
OH, MY GOD.
YOU MEAN ARMED SECURITY IN
SCHOOLS?
YOU'RE CRIMINALIZING THE
SCHOOLS.
IT'S LIKE, NO.
THESE ARE NOT NEW IDEAS.
THESE ARE IDEAS WE HAVE TALKED
ABOUT.
IT DRIVES ME CRAZY.
IT SHOWS WIND ANCHORS AND PEOPLE
GET THE VAPORS OVER THIS STUFF.
THEY CORDON THEMSELVES OFF FROM
PEOPLE WITH ACTUAL, SENSIBLE
IDEAS.
INSTEAD OF SAYING DO SOMETHING
AND GETTING ANGRY AND EMOTIONAL,
THESE ARE ACTUALLY PRACTICAL
SOLUTIONS.
BUT WE HAVE TALKED ABOUT THESE
FOR YEARS.
>> Kimberly: DANA, WHAT DO YOU
MAKE OF IT?
THE LAST 48 HOURS IN TERMS OF
DISCUSSIONS, THE PEOPLE THAT
CAME TO SEE, THE PEOPLE BROUGHT
TOGETHER IN THE IDEAS.
"THE FIVE" I THINK IT'S BEEN
SUPER INTERESTING.
I WAS THINKING ABOUT IT TODAY.
TALKING ABOUT THE PRESIDENT.
I THINK THE CNN TOWN HALL WAS
SOMETHING DIFFERENT.
DIFFERENT TONE AND TENOR.
ONE OF THE THINGS YOU DO AT THE
WHITE HOUSE, I THINK THEY STILL
HAVE IT, POLICY TIME WITH THE
PRESIDENT.
THIS IS USUALLY SOMETHING THAT'S
DEFINITELY NOT ON CAMERA.
AND EVERYBODY WHO HAS A SEAT AT
THE TABLE, USUALLY SENIOR STAFF
AND RELEVANT FEDERAL AGENCIES,
EITHER THE SECRETARY OR DEPUTY,
ARE THERE AND THEY THROW OUT
THEIR IDEAS ARE THE PRESIDENT
CAN SAY YES, NO.
YOU ARE WATCHING THAT IN REAL
TIME TODAY.
A COUPLE TIMES THE PRESIDENT
JUMPED IN AND SAID I DON'T LIKE
THE ACTIVE SHOOTER DRILLS.
I DON'T LIKE IT AND HE EXPLAIN
WHY.
FOR CHILDREN IT WOULD BE
TRAUMATIC AND WHY WOULD WE WANT
TO DO THAT TO THEM?
IT WAS INTERESTING TO SEE THAT.
YOU ALSO HAVE A SITUATION WHERE
PRESIDENT IN REAL-TIME IS
TALKING ABOUT IDEAS THAT AREN'T
TOTALLY FLESHED OUT.
WHEN SOMEBODY SAYS THE NRA IS
NOT GOING TO SUPPORT THAT.
YES, THEY WILL.
THEN THE NRA SAYS NO, WE DON'T
SUPPORT IT WHEN IT COMES TO
RAISING THE AGE LIMIT.
HE IS NOT AFRAID TO WALK OVER
HOT COALS THAT MOST POLITICIANS
AREN'T WILLING TO DO.
I WILL TRY THAT.
I AM FOR THAT.
WHY DON'T WE TRY THAT?
THEY BE AT THE END OF THIS WE
WILL END UP WITH THE BUMP STOCK
THING.
MAYBE SOMETHING ON THE STATE
LEVEL.
DEALING WITH PROTECTING SCHOOLS
IN HARD TARGETS.
I THINK SOME OF THAT HAS TO COME
FROM A LOCAL LEVEL.
PEOPLE GETTING REAL SPECIFIC.
THE PRESIDENT SAID WHAT ABOUT
GIVING TEACHERS BONUSES IF THEY
ARE ADEPT AT USING WEAPONS AND
THEY COULD BE ONE OF THESE
TEACHERS AND WE COULD GIVE THEM
A LITTLE BIT OF BONUS AND
INCENTIVE MONEY.
THE SCHOOL BOARD PERSON SAYS
COULD YOU TELL US HOW WE MIGHT
PAY FOR THAT?
WE DON'T EVER HAVE EXTRA MONEY.
THE PRESIDENT IS LIKE WE WILL
WORK ON THAT LATER.
YOU ARE WATCHING POLICYMAKING IN
REAL TIME RATHER THAN GETTING IT
ALL FINISHED IN A NICE PACKAGE
WITH A BOW AND PRESENTING IT TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> Greg: I LOVE THE BONUS
IDEA.
IT WAS A GREAT IDEA.
>> Dana: IT IS A BUSINESSMAN'S
IDEA.
>> Kimberly: IT MAKES SENSE.
WHAT DID YOU THINK, JESSE?
YOU WERE VERY MOVED, AS WE ALL
WERE YESTERDAY.
TODAY WAS I THINK SIGNIFICANT
FOLLOW-UP.
>> Jesse: I'M STRUCK BY HOW
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY AS THE
PARTY OF IDEAS.
TO GREG'S POINT, YOU'VE HAD SO
MANY SPECIFIC IDEAS COME OUT
FROM THE PRESIDENT'S MOUTH ABOUT
SOLVING THE ISSUE.
YOU'VE HAD A LOT OF SPECIFIC
IDEAS COMING FROM THE
PRESIDENT'S MOUTH ABOUT SOLVING
INTEGRATION.
WE SAW THE SAME KIND OF ORGANIC,
HOW THE SAUSAGE IS MADE KIND OF
MEETING WITH THE IMMIGRATION
THING.
YOU ARE SEEING IT WITH GUNS NOW
AND I AM NOT HEARING THE SAME
SORT OF IDEAS FROM THE
DEMOCRATIC SIDE OF THE AISLE.
I DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT THE
DEMOCRATS WANT TO DO ON GUNS.
I KNOW THEY DON'T LIKE GUNS.
I KNOW THEY WANT TO BAN AR-15s
BUT IN TERMS OF SCHOOL SAFETY,
WHAT IS THE DEMOCRATS' POSITION
ON SCHOOL SAFETY?
I DON'T KNOW WHAT IT IS.
MAYBE JUAN CAN ENLIGHTEN ME.
WE HAVE JUST RATTLED OFF REALLY
GREAT IDEAS IN THE PRESIDENT, TO
HIS CREDIT, IS LEADING HIS PARTY
AWAY FROM THE KIND OF STRICT I'M
NOT GOING TO DO ANYTHING ON GUNS
STANDS THEY'VE HAD IN THE PAST.
IT IS A TIRED ANALOGY.
IT IS THE "NIXON GOES TO CHINA"
ANALOGY.
I HATE TO USE IT BUT IT'S
APPROPRIATE HERE.
IF ANYONE CAN DO IT ON GUNS OR
GUN SAFETY, IT'S GOING TO BE
PRESIDENT DONALD J. TRUMP.
THE DEMOCRATS LIKE TO SAY THE
KINDERGARTEN TEACHER WHO IS
80 YEARS OLD, MISS EDELMAN, IT'S
GOING TO BE PACKING A
9-MILLIMETER ON HER WAY TO
TEACHING ONE PLUS ONE IS TOO.
THAT'S A SCARE TACTIC.
HE'S TALKING ABOUT JANITORS OR
BUREAUCRATS OR ADMINISTRATORS OR
TEACHERS THAT ARE TRAINED AND
HAVE LICENSES, HAVING LOCKED UP
WEAPON SO WHEN THE ALARM GOES
OFF THEY CAN DO THAT.
I DON'T SEE WHAT THE PROBLEM IS
WITH THAT.
DEMOCRATS SEEM TO WANT TO BAN
BAD GUYS AND GOOD GUYS FROM
HAVING WEAPONS.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY WE WOULD
BAN GOOD GUYS.
>> Kimberly: JUAN, WHAT'D YOU
THINK ABOUT THE LAST TWO DAYS?
>> Juan: THE SIGNAL IS THE
YOUNG PEOPLE COMING OUT IN THE
WAY THEY HAVE BECOMING A FORCE
OF THE POLITICAL DISCUSSION
ABOUT GUNS IN THE AFTERMATH OF
WHAT TOOK PLACE IN PARKLAND.
THE OTHER SIDE OF IT THAT'S MORE
FASCINATING TO ME IN A SAD WAY
IS THE ATTACK ON THE KIDS THAT
HAVE COME FROM THE RIGHT,
CALLING THEM ACTORS AND PUPPETS.
ABSOLUTELY BELITTLING YOUNG
PEOPLE BECAUSE THEY STAND UP AND
SAY HEY, THIS IS IMPACTING OUR
LIVES.
ENOUGH IS ENOUGH.
DO SOMETHING.
I THINK IT IS A CRY THAT'S BEING
HEARD AROUND THE COUNTRY.
TO ME, WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
THINGS LIKE LET'S ARE MOST
SCHOOLS, WHICH SEEMS TO ME THE
NUMBER ONE IDEA COMING FROM
PRESIDENT TRUMP, I THINK YOU ARE
ENLISTING THEM IN THE NRA ARMY
BECAUSE YOU ARE SAYING EVERYBODY
HAS TO HAVE GUNS.
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE TO HAVE
GUNS EVERYWHERE, EVEN AROUND OUR
CHILDREN.
WITH THE PROLIFERATION OF GUNS
IN SCHOOLS, I THINK YOU CAN
ANTICIPATE THERE ARE GOING TO BE
MORE GUN INCIDENTS AND SCHOOLS.
TO ME, THAT'S NOT A GOOD IDEA.
I THINK WHAT WE WANT TO DO IS
SEEK CLEARLY.
THE PROBLEM IS BECAUSE OF THE
NRA AND ITS POWER OVER THE
POLITICIANS, YOU GET INTO A
SITUATION LIKE YOU HAD LAST
NIGHT AT THE CNN EVENT OR MARCO
RUBIO, HE IS SAYING I AM FOR
LOWERING THE AGE LIMIT WHICH IS
WHAT PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS SAID
WITH REGARD FOR GUNS.
PEOPLE SAY OH, NO.
WHAT ABOUT --
>> Greg: YOU ARE A FIXATION ON
THE NRA IS YOUR WAY OUT OF A
DEBATE.
>> Juan: NO, I'M GLAD TO
HAVE --
>> Greg: WHAT WE TALKED ABOUT.
>> Juan: I SAID I THINK ARMING
SCHOOLS IS ESSENTIALLY ASKING
ALL OF US TO ENLIST IN THE NRA
ARMY SO WE DON'T HAVE --
>> Kimberly: WAYNE LaPIERRE
OFFERED A FIERCE DEFENSE OF THE
NIGHT.
>> IF THEY TRULY CARED, WHAT
THEY WOULD DO IS THEY WOULD
PROTECT THEM.
FOR THEM, IT'S NOT A SAFETY
ISSUE.
IT'S A POLITICAL ISSUE.
THEIR GOAL IS TO ELIMINATE THE
SECOND AMENDMENT.
AND OUR FIREARMS FREEDOMS SO
THEY CAN ERADICATE ALL
INDIVIDUAL FREEDOMS.
EVIL MUST BE CONFRONTED
IMMEDIATELY WITH ALL NECESSARY
FORCE TO PROTECT OUR KIDS.
TO STOP A BAD GUY WITH A GUN, IT
TAKES A GOOD GUY WITH A GUN.
>> Kimberly: THAT WAS A LINE
THAT WAS WELL RECEIVED BY THE
CROWD.
>> Greg: IT IS A WELL-WORN
LINE.
WE'VE HEARD IT BEFORE.
IT'S TRUE.
IF YOU WANT AN EXAMPLE, WHAT
HE'S TALKING ABOUT.
LISTEN TO THE POLICE CHIEF LAST
NIGHT.
I KNOW WE ARE GOING TO TALK
ABOUT THE CNN TOWN HALL IN THE
BUTTER BE BLOCKED.
GOVERNMENT, SOMETIMES THAT
POLICE CHIEF CAN'T PROTECT YOU.
THEY WENT TO THAT KID'S HOUSE
HOW MANY TIMES?
THEY HAD HOW MANY, 30 SOME ODD
INSTANCES.
AND THEY BOOED THE NRA AT THAT
TOWN HALL.
WHEN I LISTEN TO THAT POLICE
CHIEF, PRIVATE CITIZEN SECURITY
OR TRAIN PERSONNEL, COULD HAVE
STOPPED THIS BECAUSE THE POLICE
DIDN'T.
THAT IS THE THING.
SOMETIMES GOVERNMENT JUST CAN'T
BE THERE.
I GO BACK TO THE OTHER STATISTIC
THAT'S BEEN USED.
THE DURATION OF A GUN THE ATTACK
IS DICTATED BY THE ARRIVAL OF A
SECOND GUN.
IF THE GUN IS ALREADY THERE, DO
THE MATH.
>> Juan: LET ME TELL YOU
SOMETHING THAT STOOD OUT TO ME
WATCHING WAYNE LAST YEAR.
I THOUGHT WAYNE LaPIERRE AT
CPAC, THIS IS GOING TO BE WAYNE
LaPIERRE BEING ENDORSED,
APPLAUDED.
I THOUGHT THIS IS GOING TO BE
THEIR MOMENT BECAUSE THIS IS
THEIR CROWD.
AT ONE POINT WAYNE LaPIERRE
SAYS IT'S AWFULLY QUIET.
I GUESS YOU SHOULD BE AFRAID.
I THINK THERE ARE LOTS OF PEOPLE
WHO IDENTIFY AS CONSERVATIVES
AND GUN RIGHTS SUPPORTERS WHO
ARE UNCOMFORTABLE AT THIS MOMENT
AND I THINK THAT'S GREAT.
>> Greg: YOU ARE LOOKING AT A
TRANSITION AT THE NRA.
I THINK HE IS THE OLD FACE OF
THE NRA.
>> Kimberly: DON'T TELL HIM
THAT.
>> Greg: HE WOULDN'T BE HAPPY.
DANA LOHSE, A YOUNG, STRONG
WOMAN WHO CAN ARTICULATE THIS
IDEA AND BRAVE ENOUGH.
CNN OFFERED SUCH A GREAT DEAL TO
DANA LASCH.
DON'T COME AND WE WILL MAKE FUN
OF YOU OR COME AND WE WILL MAKE
FUN OF YOU.
>> Jesse: I WANT TO ADDRESS
SOMETHING YOU SAID IN THE
BEGINNING.
HE SAID WE ARE GOING TO ARM THE
SCHOOLS.
THAT'S NOT ACCURATE.
NOT EVERY TEACHER GETS A GUN.
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO HAVE KURDS
ABOVE THE SCHOOL, WITH MACHINE
GUNS SWEEPING THE GROUNDS.
THAT'S INSANE.
YOU ARE SAYING YOU ARE ENLISTING
THEM IN THE NRA ARMY.
THAT IS JUST RHETORIC, JUAN.
IF YOU GIVE ONE TEACHER, A
TRAINED TEACHER, A WEAPON TO
THEN USE TO NEUTRALIZE A SCHOOL
SHOOTER BEFORE POLICE CAN GET
THERE, THAT'S PRACTICAL.
YOU FEEL SAFER BEING PROTECTED
BY WEAPONS WHEN YOU'RE AT A
FOOTBALL GAME.
HER AT A RAVENS GAME.
THERE IS ONE POLICE OFFICER
ARMED FOR EACH 1,000 FANS.
THAT'S A GOOD RATIO.
IF YOU HAVE A HIGH SCHOOL WITH A
THOUSAND PEOPLE YOU HAVE ONE
ARMED PERSON.
THAT'S NOT AN ARMY FROM THE NRA.
THE NRA IS CREATED TO BE A
BOGEYMAN.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE STATISTICS,
THE NRA DOESN'T DONATE THAT MUCH
MONEY TO POLITICIANS COMPARED TO
OTHER PEOPLE.
THEY DONATE LESS THAN UNIONS.
THEY DONATE LESSON PLANNED
PARENTHOOD.
THEY DON'T CRACK THE TOP 50 IN
TERMS OF LOBBYING OUTFITS.
I KNOW THE NRA IS POWERFUL IN
YOUR MIND BUT A LOT OF THE
POLITICIANS THAT VOTE WITH THE
NRA AREN'T DOING IT BECAUSE THEY
ARE BEHOLDEN BECAUSE THEY ARE
GETTING A LOT OF DONATIONS.
YOU CAN'T BUY A POLITICIAN FOR
$2500.
THEY VOTE WITH THE
SECOND AMENDMENT BECAUSE THEY
BELIEVE IN THE SECOND AMENDMENT.
>> Dana: ONE OTHER THING,
WHICH IS THE POSSIBLE THINGS
CHANGING.
ONE OF THEM HAS TO DO WITH
SOMETHING THAT'S BEEN A THORN IN
THE SIDE OF A LOT OF PEOPLE FOR
A LONG TIME ESPECIALLY ON THE
LEFT.
THE CENTERS FOR DISEASE CONTROL,
BECAUSE OF AN AMENDMENT PASSED
25 YEARS AGO, HAS NOT BEEN
ALLOWED AND HAS NOT BEEN FUNDED
TO STUDY GUN VIOLENCE AND MENTAL
ILLNESS AND GUN VIOLENCE.
ALL OF THOSE THINGS GET -- ONE
OF THE THINGS WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
IS IT'S BETTER TO MAKE DECISIONS
BASED ON EVIDENCE AND FACTS AND
RESEARCH SO YOU CAN BE LOGICAL
ABOUT IT AND TRY TO SOLVE THE
RIGHT PROBLEM.
THERE'S BEEN CHANGES NOW.
IT LOOKS LIKE, AT LEAST THE
SECRETARY OF HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES, ALEC CESAR, LOOKS LIKE
HE'S WILLING.
HE WAS IN A HEARING LAST WEEK TO
LOOK AT THE ISSUE.
PUT SOME MONEY TOWARD IT.
EVEN THE PERSON, IT'S CALLED THE
DICKEY AMENDMENT, FORMER
CONGRESSMAN DICKEY'S THINKING I
DIDN'T MEAN FOR THIS TO ACTUALLY
HAPPEN OVER 25 YEARS.
I AM OKAY WITH HAVING RESEARCH
DONE.
MIGHT BE A SMALL THING BUT IF
YOU ARE WANTING TO MAKE
DECISIONS BASED ON RESEARCH,
THEN THERE MIGHT BE A WAY
FORWARD.
>> Juan: DO YOU KNOW WHY THAT
IS?
DOLLAR FROM THE NRA THAT HAS
SHUT THAT DOWN AND MADE IT A
POLITICAL ISSUE.
>> Dana: I KNOW.
I USED TO ANSWER QUESTIONS ABOUT
IT ALL THE TIME.
>> Juan: OBVIOUSLY NOT THAT
POWERFUL.
THEY ARE NOW OPEN TO DOING IT.
>> Juan: 25 YEARS.
THAT'S HOW DIFFICULT IT'S BEEN.
GREG SAID LET'S HAVE REAL IDEAS
IN REAL CONVERSATIONS BUT I
THINK THE OPPOSITE OF YOU.
GETS SHUT DOWN BY PEOPLE WHO ARE
FEARFUL OF THE NRA.
>> Greg: I REMEMBER SOMEBODY
NAMED PRESIDENT OBAMA WENT AT
SENATE AND CONGRESS.
DEMOCRAT.
>> Jesse: MAJORITY IN THE
SENATE AND THEY VOTED ON THE
ASSAULT WEAPONS BAN.
16 DEMOCRATS VOTED AGAINST IT.
NINE ARE STILL IN THE SENATE.
>> Juan: I AM SAYING PEOPLE
ARE FEARFUL OF HAVING AN HONEST
DISCUSSION.
>> Greg: YOU SAY PEOPLE WHEN
YOU MEAN DEMOCRAT.
>> Juan: NO, NO.
REPUBLICANS ARE LOCKED TO THE
NRA AND DEMOCRATS ARE FEARFUL IF
THEY SAY ANYTHING, THEY WILL
SUFFER AT THE BALLOT BOX.
>> Greg: I THINK YOU CREATE
THIS IN YOUR HEAD SO YOU DON'T
WANT TO TALK ABOUT SOLUTIONS.
YOU CREATE THIS BIG "WE CAN'T DO